[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday October 6th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the death of a 22 year old Iranian woman
Masa amini while in police custody last
month has sparked protests throughout
Iran crowds have clashed with security
forces and women have burned their
headscarves in a rejection of the
country's strict laws on women's attire
after Iran restricted internet access to
try and curb the protests the Biden
Administration and Elon Musk both
stepped forward to say they'd help
protesters stay connected but that
promise has been hard to execute on and
it's left demonstrators struggling to
keep their messages private from the
government while getting the word out to
other protesters and the rest of the
world
joining us to explain the situation is
our Middle East correspondent David
Cloud hi David thanks for joining me
good to be here David can you start by
giving us a rundown of what internet
access looks like in Iran right now in
the last two weeks the Iranian
government has imposed pretty tight
restrictions on use of the internet
particularly at night they shut down the
system and put blocks on the system and
prevent people from using email all
sorts of techniques to prevent people
from communicating particularly within
the country they don't want protesters
communicating but they also don't want
them beaming video outside the country
that people like journalists and
activists and others use in recent days
we've also seen activists and computer
Engineers arrested so it's a pretty wide
scale Crackdown on on internet use and
internet expertise now protesters are
still trying to get access to the
internet to communicate with each other
to communicate with the outside world
and talk to us a little bit about how
they're trying to do that they are and I
should say you know the internet is not
fully shut down even Iran a very close
country can't afford to do that frankly
they still need it for all sorts of
reasons many of the same reasons we
needed here you know in the west uh
economic transactions communication the
regime uses it for communication so they
can't completely shut it down but people
are worried about their safety in
communicating and in sending videos so
you know thousands of people are trying
to set up vpns and have set up vpns
virtual private networks they're using
encrypted email all right so the US
government did lift some export controls
to help Iranians get unrestricted access
to the internet and then Elon Musk
tweeted that starlink from his company
SpaceX had been activated in the country
has that made difference so far I mean
star length if it works it offers a way
to get sort of independent access to the
internet through an orbiting satellite
however it's a logistical nightmare to
make it work you got to get the
terminals into Iran which you know
hasn't happened on a very large scale
you have to get the terminals linked to
the satellite it all has to work and
there's also the possibility that the
regime will jam it I mean there's no
doubt that they have the capability of
finding these signals and jamming them
you spoke with some Iranians trying to
set up a starlink connection can you
tell us about their experience one of
them is a computer engineer the other
one his identity is unknown to me so
this account comes from the computer
engineer they obtained two starlink
terminals from Dubai which is right
across the Persian Gulf from Iran and
had been trying even before the protests
broke out to connect to the satellites
and had not been able to do so when the
protest broke out and they heard Elon
musk's assertion that that starlink was
now activated in Iran they got quite
excited and optimistic and went onto the
roof of a house in an Iranian City and
again attempted to connect the Starling
terminal to the satellite what I was
told was they got a signal very briefly
for a few seconds from the satellite
then it disappeared so they haven't been
able to get access to the internet using
starlink has SpaceX commented on that
starlink has not uh commented nor has
SpaceX we sent them detailed questions
about what we heard from this Iranian
computer engineer and about his
experience and they didn't respond to
comment and I want to take a second to
focus on SpaceX we saw them provide
internet access in Ukraine during the
war how important are these crises to
spacex's efforts to get starlink you
know more widely used
I don't think it's Central to their
business model at all they say have said
they have around 400 000 users worldwide
I would expect these are Travelers these
are people who go to rural areas and
need access to the internet
I don't think the system is designed for
conflict zones particularly not conflict
zones like Iran which have repressive
governments and which you know tightly
control access to the internet it was
used in Ukraine after Russia invaded But
Ukraine's government wanted starlink
they wanted to be able to sustain
internet access for it for people so
what comes next then for the protesters
who are trying to get internet access to
spread their message outside of Iran
what comes next I mean I think they just
have to keep trying and keep working at
it it's not going to be easy in some
ways
internet access is not the critical
thing I mean yes it's nice to know
what's going on there and it's important
to know what's going on there obviously
it helps the protests gain International
support it helps sustain their momentum
I suppose but no I think they're going
to have to use the techniques that they
have been using and to try to find more
ways to do it I mean VPN networks using
access to the internet when it's
available and sending out videos Etc I
mean there aren't great options unless
something like starlink you know becomes
widely available
all right we'll have to leave it there
David Cloud wsj Middle East
correspondent thank you so much for
joining us my pleasure
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]